>>DeWitt: So, good morning.
Good morning.
I hope everybody enjoyed the part of the keynote
you were there for and then the last 10 minutes
here.
Sorry it ran a little long. Our guests -- it's
15 minutes of extra awesome for everyone.
So we have a lot to cover today and we are
actually Live Waving this.
We're transcribing this in a Wave and you
can get to that Wave, if you have your laptop
open, at goo.gl/Ze99.
And embedded in that Wave is a Google moderator.
So if you have questions for us, please put
them in the Google moderator because
we may run short on time for Q&A at the end.
We'll go back and we'll – Jeff and I will
fill out everything after the fact.
So my name is DeWitt and this is Jeff.
>>Jeff: Hi.
>>DeWitt: And we're software engineers here
at Google.
And as software developers yourselves you
know that Google has many different APIs,
a platform on which for you to build.
I think we have over 60 different product
APIs right now.
But one thing you may not have known is how
easy it is to use those APIs and what we are
going to show you today is ways to bring Google
technologies -- the power search, and content,
and revenue, and interactivity -- and a surprise
launch right at the end – and bring these
to your site using very simple techniques,
something that anybody in
this room can do.
I'd like to start this today by handing it
to Jeff, who will talk about Google Custom
Search and bringing that to your web site.
Jeff?
>>Jeff: Thanks. Okay. So one of the things
that Google is best known for is
search and for a while we've had a product
called Google Custom Search.
I'm gonna give a quick overview of what it
is and then talk about a couple of new
tricks that we've recently taught to Custom
Search.
So to begin with, Custom Search is really
all about creating your own search engine
using Google's technologies in the background.
So with Custom Search you define a slice of
the web that you want Google to index, and
rank, and do all the things that Google has
gotten good at doing for your particular slice
of the web that you're interested in.
And then we give you a way to embed this Custom
Search box that you've created onto your site.
So let's take a look at an example.
[pause]
Here's one I created earlier.
All right.
So we have our search box here and maybe we'll
search for something.
This is -- this is actually a Custom Search
Engine that I defined earlier using some of
the sites on Google code, and some of our
blogs and video channels, things like that.
So does anybody have a suggestion?
Anything they're interested in?
Just shout it out.
>>Audience Member: Flowers.
>>Jeff: Flowers.
>>DeWitt: App Engine.
>>Jeff: App Engine.
There's a good one.
All right.
Okay.
So here we have, we have our search results.
We've actually applied a theme which is something
we created a little while ago, a way to make
the look and feel of this fit into your site.
So you can see, I have a few tabs here.
I've actually created some refinements.
So for example, here, I'm just looking at
blogs that were, were indexed as part of this
Custom Search Engine.
Now, the code for this is actually very simple
and you actually don't even need to understand
JavaScript and HTML to be able to use it.
We can look at the source for this.
This is the entire page right here, just a
few lines.
And I brought up a larger view here.
Right.
So we can see that there's just a few lines
of HTML and JavaScript and we actually give
you a tool to generate this for you.
We have something called a "web element" which
is basically a graphical way to configure
the look and feel and define the scope of
your Custom Search Engine.
We have sort of a zero configuration option
which is this automatically search my site.
Whatever site you put this code on, if you
have that as your option, that particular
site defines the scope of the search engine.
So then your search box will be just for that
domain.
All right.
So I mentioned some new tricks and I'm going
to show you one of these right now.
I'm going to take my demo site and go to this
super secret URL.
>>DeWitt: [Laughing]
>>Jeff: Okay.
And we have what looks to be the same thing
and I'm gonna show this quickly before you
guys view source and figure out what I changed.
So this time maybe I'll look for Ajax.
>>DeWitt: Whoa!
>>Jeff: And hey.
>>DeWitt: Look at that.
>>Jeff: What do you know? That's new.
>>DeWitt: Are those autocompletions?
>>Jeff: Yes, they are. Thank you. So..
[audience applauds]
>>Jeff: So today we are making available auto
completions for Custom Search Engines.
So this is now available for all filter Custom
Search Engines.
And setting this up is quite simple.
First you'll go to google.com/cse which is
where you can manage your Custom Search engines
that you've created and there's a new option
now available which allows you to enable auto
completions for particular Custom Search Engine.
And then you'll also need to make a couple
of changes in that code I showed earlier.
Where you see we just really add a couple
lines here.
So we're setting a draw option, controlling
how this is rendered, and one of the new options
is enabling auto complete.
All right.
So that's one of the new things in Custom
Search.
Another is actually extending this idea of
themes and actually taking the customizability
to a whole new level.
So ratcheting up the custom in Custom Search.
So with these new templates and this new theming
system you can actually create a fully customized
rendering for your search results.
This works best just to show you an example.
I'm gonna bring up a site here.
Dishola.com is a site that's all about reviewing
specific dishes at, at restaurants and the
group that's behind it actually started working
on an experimental mobile interface which
is living at dishfork.appspot.com.
I thought that was kind of a clever name.
So we'll take a look at this site here.
So this is really designed for a mobile view.
You can see here that if I search for something
like "cake", we have this interface that comes
up and what may be surprising is that all
of this is powered through Custom Search.
All of this content has been indexed in a
Custom Search Engine and all of the rendering
is using the Custom Search JavaScript.
So we can take a look, we can click through
some of these.
And see, they've embedded a map, they've got
an average user rating, some different tags.
And all of these are actually stored in the
index as something called "rich snippets".
This is a way that you can take specific pieces
of structured content on your site and actually
expose this as part of your user interface.
Now, if we look at the source for this page,
I mentioned that they've created this entire
UI using this new templating system.
You can actually see here, this is their template
right here.
It basically defined how each of these pieces,
the rich snippets, the results, the links,
how they're going to be laid out on the page
and how they're going to be styled.
Now, this is a lot.
They really went crazy with this.
But to look at a simplified example, if we're
just looking at the thumbnail image, this
is a quick idea just to give you a flavor
of what this looks like.
Here you can see we're looking for a rich
snippet, we're saying where we want to render
it on the page.
And if you want to learn more about this,
this templating system, you can actually look
at our documentation on code.google.com.
All right.
So now we've looked at a way that you can
expose the content that's on your site through
a Custom Search Engine.
And we're going to look at something new,
change direction a little bit, and talk about
some ways to bring new content into your site.
And for that, I'll turn it over to DeWitt.
>>DeWitt:
Good.
Thanks, Jeff.
So really quickly, you may have heard -- this
is confidential – that, that blogs are dead,
that RSS is dead, feeds are dead.
The people who say that, I'm not sure where
they're getting their data 'cause we've seen
year, after year, after year continued growth
in the number of feeds, the
number of feed consumers.
The popularity of feeds continues to grow
and one of the ways that people get to feeds
is using the Google Feed API.
So the Google Feed API converts RSS or Atom
feeds, published by publishers, into a normalized
form in JSON, and then allows that JSON to
be embedded in web browsers.
It's, it's grown and grown and grown.
We're now doing well over a hundred million
requests for feeds over the Feed API every
single day.
And why don't I show you an example of a site
that's using the Google Feed API.
So you're all familiar with The New Yorker
magazine.
The New Yorker publishes RSS feeds for their
recent articles and restaurant reviews.
The content on their site is exposed via feeds
and if you look at their home page, what's
interesting is it's very rich, very dynamic,
brings in a tremendous amount of content.
And you'll see down here sections -- the movie
section, the reporting an essay section.
Those are actually brought in from their RSS
feeds and what brings them into this page,
which is dynamically rendered in the browser,
is the Google Feed API and I'll show you how
they're using this.
So we do a search for "google load" you'll
see that they're loading the Feed API and
then loading their own RSS feed, and then
dynamically rendering it on the page.
[pause]
They do this using a surprisingly small amount
of code.
So it's about ten lines of code to load and
fetch a feed in a web browser, normalize it,
and then iterate over each entry, and then
rendering it on the page using HTML and CSS.
So this is interesting and to talk about exactly
how it works we need to go into a little more
detail about how feeds in general work.
So you have feed publishers.
So you have The New Yorker, you have the New
York Times, you have the TechCrunch.
They publish either RSS or Atom and they publish
them to the web.
And on the other hand you have feed subscribers.
This could be Google Reader, it could be blog
lines, it could be Outlook, it could be Firefox.
So those are feed subscribers.
One thing that cannot be a feed subscriber,
unfortunately, is the browser.
So as a security feature, browsers have what's
known as a "same origin" policy.
It prevents third-party content from being
loaded into a page from a domain that's different
than the page it was surfed off itself.
So we can't do what we see in this image.
We can't load from the browser directly from
the publisher.
For that, we need the Google Feed API.
So what the Google Feed API does is it retrieves
the RSS or the Atom feed, it converts it into
JSON, and then it serves it back out to the
browser using a technique called JSONP.
So that allows the third-party content to
be embedded in the context of the page.
We just saw this on The New Yorker.com.
This works.
It's successful but can you see the problem
with it?
Well, the problem is those lines that are
going back and forth on the screen.
The fetch and the response.
Fetch and the response.
Or as we joke, it's like the kid in the backseat
going, "are we there yet? Are we there yet?
"
Over and over and over again.
This introduces a tremendous amount of latency.
You have to fetch the feed right after it
was published to get the update quickly and
it's also a lot of wasted energy.
We spend a lot of time fetching stuff that
doesn't exist.
The answer is usually, no, we're not there
yet.
To solve this problem on the servers, a lot
of us in the industry have been working on
a protocol called PubSubHubbub and it's as
fun to say as it is to use.
PubSubHubbub is actually fantastic.
What it does is it introduces a hub in between
the feed publisher and the subscribers.
So when, say, TechCrunch has a new entry up,
they ping their hub, the hub goes and fetches
the update, and then broadcasts it out to
all of the subscribers so Google Reader will
get the update in, say, 2 seconds rather than
in 5 minutes.
So PubSubHubbub is rapidly accelerating, if
you'll forgive the pun, the real-time web.
So here's where we are today.
We have the Google Feed API wired up to PubSubHubbub.
So a entry posted on TechCrunch will make
it to the Feed API in a second.
You see what's going on here?
The browsers are still pulling the Google
Feed API.
So even though we can get it up to Google
in a second, it's -- you have to refresh the
page to get it down to the browser.
Wouldn't it be great if we could change that?
So we did. I'm very pleased to announce today
the Google Feed API with Push all the way
to the browser.
And I wasn't gonna show you guys this but
it kinda went viral this week so.
>> One of the Google Feed API you can easily
add content from your favorite feed to your
web site.
For instance, here's an example matchup showing
entries from a couple of my personal feeds.
This is great for adding rich content to your
site and is easy to implement using a few
lines of JavaScript.
The problem is that your visitors will only
see new content when they reload the page
and even then only after Google has recrawled
the feed.
Enter the new Google Feed API version 2, now
with Push updates.
Just make a couple of changes to the code
and your visitors will be able to receive
updates pushed to their browser without a
refresh.
Let's see how this works.
Here's the demo again but this time with Push
enabled.
Now I'll go post an update on my blog.
As I submit this post, Word Press is adding
the new post to its feed and pinging the PubSubHubbub
hub.
The hub will then fetch the new content and
send it to all subscribed servers, including
Google servers, which send it to all subscribed
browsers.
And there you go.
The update arrived within seconds on my page
and it would have done the same for anyone
who was looking at that page at the same time
as us.
For more information, please see the documentation
at code.gooogle.com/apis/feed/push.
>>DeWitt: So we are extremely excited about
this.
Let me just show you the code again.
In order to go from a polling based feed subscription
using the Google Feed API we can go to a push-based
subscription model simply by changing to Feed
API version 2, changing the constructer there,
and changing the load to a subscribe.
Fantastically simple.
We think this is going to enable a whole new
type of application in the web browser.
We are going to be rolling this out over the
next couple weeks.
If you are interested and wanna start trying
it soon, please visit us as google.com -- code.google.com/apis/feed/push.
And if you're interested in all the technical
details behind this, and there are plenty,
please join Bret at the Realtime Web -- Realtime
Web Apps talk tomorrow at 1:00 p.m. right
back in this room and that'll be a lot of
fun.
And now Jeff is going to talk about one way
to bring more revenue to your web site.
So we showed you search, we showed you content,
and now we'll talk about revenue.
Jeff.
>>Jeff: Thanks.
Okay.
So we've shown some ways to bring great content
to your site, either exposing it through search
or bringing in new content, and now that your
users are there and have a lot of stuff to
do on your site, maybe now is the right time
to think about ways that you can bring in
some revenue.
One way that people do this is through a e-commerce
store front.
Something like this, you know.
There are several different solutions out
there.
A lot of them have sort of a similar look
and feel, something like this.
You usually have an image of what you're selling,
a description, price, you have a shopping
cart so that people can continue to browse
around and add things to their cart, purchasing
them all at the end.
And setting up these sites is not trivial;
right?
There's usually a little configuration and
coding involved and we at Google wanted to
see just how easy we could make this.
So I actually set up one of these earlier
using this new Google Checkout element.
We're gonna take a look at it here.
[Pause]
So this is a simple store here that I set
up all about selling stickers for your laptop.
See, I went with kind of a theme here.
And for some of these, you can add them to
your cart, you can change quantities.
Let's see.
I want a few of these.
You can select different sizes, things like
that.
You can change your mind.
Right.
All of this is kinda standard stuff.
But what's surprising about this is how very
little code is actually required to get this
set up.
In fact, if we view source, we can see right
here this is the entire code for the page
and this right here is actually what's driving
all of this.
So we have here a gadget that's actually embedded
and loaded on the page and the great thing
about this is that the content for this is
actually all pulled out of a Google spread
sheet.
So I noticed actually that I made a mistake
here.
So there's a typo here.
Turns out that apparently this sticker is
gonna make you sicker.
Probably not something that people would be
interested in.
So now I have kind of a problem where I have
to fix this and I don't know.
I have to call the webmaster.
I mean, this is -- this is gonna be a big
deal.
Well, turns out, since we're working with
a spreadsheet here and pulling all the information
dynamically as needed, I can just open the
spreadsheet and fix it right here.
There we go.
And while I'm at it, maybe I'm also having
a sale.
Yeah.
New low price.
And also this size option I'd kinda like to
do that for some of these other stickers as
well.
So I just changed the spreadsheet and when
next time someone views the page, they will
actually see the updated information.
[pause]
All right.
So here we have it.
And I can now select sizes here.
All right.
So what we've tried to do is make setting
up one of these e-commerce store fronts really
simple.
As I mentioned, you just edit a spreadsheet
and the spreadsheet containing everything
from the screen shot, to the description,
the price, and it even has this quantity column
here.
And so if someone purchases something, that
purchase is entered into the Google Checkout
Merchant Center so the merchant center is
actually handling the whole flow of the transaction.
And then when the purchase is made it actually
updates the quantity here, decreasing the
available quantity here in your spreadsheet.
So what you have now is a store gadget talking
with Google Checkout and spreadsheets all
working together.
And I think this highlights one of the great
things about Cloud computing and the fact
that your spreadsheet data lives in the cloud
and that there's an API so that you can build
these interactive applications.
You could actually build something like this
yourself.
So in continuing with our theme of you don't
have to know programming to do this, we actually
provide a configuration wizard where you can
set some options like sizes and currency and
actually get some code to copy and paste onto
your page.
All right.
So that's one way to bring in revenue through,
through actually selling something and a few
sites have started using this.
I picked a couple of examples that I thought
highlighted some interesting ways that this
could be used.
The first is one of these is being used on
a Google site.
So this site here is actually selling rose
and they didn't have to set up any of their
own servers, or know how to write HTML.
They did all of this hosted on a Google site
which has a, a nice editor and you can just
paste an iFrame right in there and it runs.
Another here, Long Live Books, actually took
some of the customization features.
So one of the things you can do in your spreadsheet
is actually have a field where people can
enter their own text.
So they use this to allow people to put their
own custom text on a book cover that they're
ordering and that text that they entered goes
into the Merchant Center along with the order,
flows through the whole, the whole process.
So we feel like there's really a lot you can
do and it's really easy to get started with
this.
All right.
So now we'd like to change gears a little
bit and talk about another way to possibly
bring revenue to your site and for that I'll
turn it back over to DeWitt.
>>DeWitt: Great.
Thanks, Jeff.
So Jeff just showed you how to run your own
store online with very little code, not even
hosting your own web servers using the Google
Check Out element.
All right.
But many of you are probably already using
a revenue-generating API, the AdSense API,
one of the most popular APIs on the web.
And what I'm going to talk about today I think
will make a number of you very, very happy.
So think about how AdSense for content works.
Google bot crawls the content of the page
and it matches relevant ads by Google with
that content on the page and presents them
to your users.
Well, this works very, very well if there
is content on the page to be crawled.
But something happened.
Sunar was talking about it earlier.
Something happened over the last couple years
and -- well, actually, you think about it,
we're kind of responsible for it -- this Ajax
revolution.
The, the growth of HTML, and JavaScript, and
CSS where the content of the page is only
created when the user is interacting with
it.
There's less to be crawled.
This has traditionally posed a problem for
AdSense for Content so we introduced a new
API, the AdSense for Content/AdSense for Ajax
API and what the AdSense for Ajax API allows
the publisher to do is pass hints about the
current content of -- content on the page
up to Google.
And also when you think about Ajax apps, they
often don't reload, the user doesn't like
hit "refresh" all the time.
The page refreshes itself with the content
on the page so the AdSense for Ajax API allows
you to dynamically update that ad blog.
Let me show you an example of this site that's
using the AdSense for Ajax API.
So here we have a site, trip.com; they're
a travel site, and what's interesting at this
travel site is if you click on these tabs
here -- it's actually a nice looking site
-- you click on these tabs here, you'll notice
the URL at the top doesn't change.
This is all being built in the browser using
HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
It's an Ajax app.
Now, look at the bottom right here.
This is an AdSense block and as we change
the tabs, you'll notice that the AdSense block
got updated based on the changed context of
the page.
So I imagine you're thinking, well, that's
gonna be a lot of programming.
No.
By now you probably figured out by now no,
it's not gonna be a lot of programming.
It's actually going to be a couple lines of
code.
I actually prefer this to the traditional
AdSense block.
You pass in a IEB size where you would like
the ad, you pass in a hint about the content
of the page, and then you simply call the
ads API to render an ad by Google for your
users into the desired dev.
And then if that content changes, you can
call the ad refresh method and refresh that
block.
So this works fantastic when you have content
on your page but there's another type of site.
It's a search engine.
So say you're running your own search engine,
you have an e-commerce site, you have a travel
site, you have a local search site.
Users are coming to you and they are typing
key words into the search box.
This intent is an incredibly powerful tool
to match relevant ads by Google with users
who are interested in it.
So we are expanding our program of AdSense
for Search Ads Only and let me show you an
example of a site that's using this.
So this is merchantcircle.com.
They are a local search engine.
So users come to the site, they type in a
keyword, they type in a geography.
And I'll do that right now.
I'll search for pizza in San Francisco.
And you will notice down here we have local
search result.
So they are running their own search index.
So we showed you earlier how to do it using
Google Custom Search.
They have their own index.
Above this, we have relevant ads by Google
that were matched against the pizza in San
Francisco query.
So this is the AdSense for Search Ads Only
program.
[pause]
Using AdSense for Search is also very simple.
In fact, I think it's even easier than the
AdSense for Ajax API.
You simply give us the pub ID; you give us
the user search query, the most important
part; you say where you would like the ad
rendered; and then you ask for an ad to be
fendered into that block and Google takes
care of the rest.
So we draw an iFrame, we make it safe, we
present that directly to your users.
And we are growing these programs and if you
are interested in joining us with these two
new AdSense features, please visit us on code.google.com
and search for AdSense.
So there's a tab on the left of the new AdSense
features.
Very excited about that.
So Jeff -- I wanna save a few minutes for
Jeff to launch something I'm thrilled to be
doing today.
But before we turn it back over to Jeff, I
wanna talk real quickly about bringing interactivity
to your site.
So how many people here are familiar with
Google Buzz?
Great.
That's everyone.
That's awesome.
I'm a big fan of Google Buzz.
I use it all the time.
I use it to communicate with my friends and
my family.
It allows me to post videos and texts, and
updates, and share 'em with my friends.
And after we launched Google Buzz, which of
course launched as part of Gmail, we heard
from publishers who said, well, this is really
nice but I'd really like to get Buzz onto
my site.
I would like my site visitors to be able to
engage via Buzz with their friends.
So we introduced the Google Buzz Button.
One of the sites that adopted this quickly
was our friends over at TechCrunch.
And you'll notice at the top of every post
on TechCrunch there's a Google Buzz button.
So let's actually press that.
And we could say "live Buzzing from Google
I/O" and when I post this, it's going to get
posted up to all of my friends and the link
will be pointing back to TechCrunch.
So that's one way to drive engagement on your
site and make your site more interactive using
Google Buzz.
You can get a Google Buzz button on your site
by going to google.com/buzz/stuff.
They're very simple to embed.
It would take anybody about three minutes
to put one on their site.
They're actually remarkably customizable.
And speaking of customization, I don't wanna
spoil the launch this afternoon but -- and
you didn't hear it from me -- come today at
1:45 to room eight and you may learn something
about Google Buzz APIs.
So that was Google Buzz.
Another way of bringing interactivity to your
site is a product that we launched called
Google SideWiki and what Google SideWiki does
is allows people as they surf the web to annotate
it.
So you see a site you like, you're able to
note -- leave a note for yourself, leave a
note for friends, about the content on that
site.
And we launched this as a tool bar and we
launched this as an extension.
So there's a Chrome extension for it.
Let me show you what the Chrome extension
looks like.
So I'll go here and I'll go to google.com
and you'll notice I have the Google Chrome
extension installed.
And if I click on it, it's supposed to pop
up.
I may be clicking too many times.
There we go.
So this pops up Google SideWiki and this is
my personal view of Google SideWiki so this
follows me around the web and here we see
that Marisa and, my friend Danny Sullivan
said Google's amazing but nothing's perfect
and I guess that's true.
And publishers asked us about the SideWiki
element and they said this is great but I
wanna know what people are saying about my
site.
In fact, if it's useful content and interactive
content, I wanna actually distribute it to
everybody who visits my site.
So they asked us for this and we launched
the Google SideWiki Element.
And what the Google SideWiki Element does
is allow the publisher to embed the public
view of the annotations of that page in the
page for everybody to see.
So now anybody who's visiting a site that's
using the SideWiki Element has the ability
to see what's going on with SideWiki.
You can get it at Google.com/webelements/sidewiki.
And before I hand it back to Jeff, I wanna
talk very briefly about one other way to make
your site more interactive.
So you may remember we launched Google Wave
at the keynote here last year, Google I/O
2009.
One of the things we showed was the ability
to take Google Wave out of the Wave interface
and embed it on a web site.
And we just recently launched that as the
Google Wave Element.
In fact, we announced that we were launching
the Google Wave Element and our friend at
Read Write Web within an hour had a blog post
up talking about the Google Wave Element and
how it can be used to embed Google Wave on
web sites.
It was cool and they got the screen shot,
and then -- wait a minute.
That's not a screen shot.
It's actually Google Wave embedded in their
site.
It's a Wave about this page.
So what Read Write Web did was – I mean
you can imagine this replacing comments for
your site -- they took a live Google Wave,
scoped to that page, embedded it on the site,
and what's very, very cool here -- so now
if we go here and we comment on it,
[pause]
I'm very high quality comment there -- this
Wave will appear automatically in my Google
Wave inbox.
So this conversation isn't static.
This conversation does not just live on Read
Write Web site.
This is a part of my Wave now and all the
interactions follow me around.
Embedding a Google Wave onto your site is
as simple as going to google.com/webelements/wave.
And like all web elements, there's a wizard
and all you have to do is configure it a little
bit.
You configure the size and then you copy and
paste.
It's about eight lines of HTML I think and
just drop that onto your page and you have
live Google Wave on every page on your site.
You can get more Google web elements, we have
I think 16 of them now, all of which bring
Google products to your site using the simple
copy and paste technique.
We showed you a few.
We showed you Google Custom Search.
We showed you Wave, SideWiki.
You can get more of these at google.com/webelements.
And with that, I'd like to hand it back to
Jeff to finish up with the launch of something
very exciting.
>>Jeff: Okay.
So quick recap of where we've been.
We've talked about ways to expose the content
on your site using Custom Search, bring new
content in now dynamically in near real time
with Push -- feeds of Push API.
And we've shown ways to possibly bring in
some revenue either through selling goods
or advertising.
And we've showed some ways to make your site
more interactive, right?
Bring --take your site's users and give them
an experience across the entire web.
All right.
So one thing that's common in all of these
is actually the text that's on the page.
It's pervasive, it's all around us and text
has been with us for thousands of years and
I predict that it'll be around for at least
a couple more.
So you heard it here first.
>>DeWitt: [Laughing]
>>Jeff: But one of the things that's, that's
kind of a challenge with text is that it's
a big part of your user experience.
So much of their time is spent reading and
you really want to have the text fit the look
and feel of your site.
It defines a lot of what your user sees.
So if you want your, your site to look the
same for everybody who's viewing it, you're
really limited in your choices.
If you want something that's available in
all browsers, all operating systems, you really
have what?
Like, five choices or something like that?
And we at Google have focused on doing a lot
of things to make the web better.
We've looked at trying to make the web faster,
make the web more accessible, the web more
powerful and we thought, gee, wouldn't it
be great if we could take the web and make
it more beautiful?
[pause]
All right.
And so to that end today we are pleased to
announce a new API, the Google Font API.
So this is a way the dynamically load fonts
onto your page so that users will have the
same experience across different browsers,
different operating systems.
And we'll take a look at some of these new
fonts that we're making available.
We tried to, to cover a wide range of styles
to really let you pick something that fits
your site and the way that it feels.
And we'll take a look at a site where we're
using this.
You've actually already seen this today and
you probably didn't even notice but the Sticker
Shop here, yeah, this banner up at the top,
our title actually isn't a picture.
It's just text.
[applause]
And you can see it.
It scales nicely as we go up, right?
As a font should.
And using this on your page is actually very
simple.
[pause]
So that slide earlier, the "Making the Web
Beautiful" slide, this is actually the full
HTML for, for that slide.
This is the whole thing.
So we've got the text down at the bottom and
we've got this link up at the top, and some
CSS and I'll actually dive into this in a
bit more detail.
So we'll look at the link first.
So this is -- as you would load a CSS file,
for example, into a site you can define this
resource that the browser should go out and
fetch and here we've said, okay, we're going
to fetch a font from the Fonts API and the
font that we picked is called "tangerine",
the name of the font there.
And so the browser now is going to go out
and fetch this and dynamically load it so
that it's now available to be used in the
page.
Now, with any fetching of resources, right,
there could potentially be some latency increase.
So we've done our best to keep the latency
down to continue to allow your users to have
a fast experience even with dynamic fonts
by doing some aggressive caching so that once
a font is loaded it should never have to be
requested again.
And in addition with these fonts we actually
serve just the font format that's appropriate
for the browser you're using.
So if your user is viewing in IE 6, 7, or
8, they get one particular file, if they're
viewing it in Firefox 3.5, or Chrome, or Opera,
or Safari, they get, they get another, and
we're also planning to support the web open
font format which is a new up and coming standard
for distributing fonts.
[pause]
All right.
Now, in addition to the caching serving just
the file that's appropriate for your browser,
we can actually batch these requests together.
So if you were using, say, three fonts on
your site, three of these, you can request
them all in just one request.
So you just have one round trip in the browser
and you get a combined download with all of
these in it.
[pause]
There's actually some more kind of narrower
scopes that you can do if you just want, say,
a particular flavor of one of these fonts.
You can actually be even more fine-grained
and there's more details documented on that.
Okay.
So we've talked about loading these new fonts.
Now, how do you use them once they're available?
Well, one way is to just use CSS just as you
would any other font, right?
You can define your font family that you're
looking for for a particular selector and
you can even chain multiple of these together,
use them as you would any other font in CSS.
We've tried to make this as seamless as possible.
[pause]
Now, another great thing that we've done is
taken this new set of fonts and the customizability
there and given you a way to try this out.
I mean, I mentioned doing some CSS and you
may not be a CSS expert so we've created something
that we hope will help you really create something
that looks great.
So I'm going to pull up this web fonts preview
tool.
This is actually an HTML5 application but
let's look at some of these fonts.
And you can select different ones.
Some of these are pretty interesting.
I like this one.
[pause]
It's right here.
You can actually do some things like change
the spacing between the words.
See it update dynamically.
Or maybe the line spacing here.
And down below what you get is actually an
updated CSS rules that you can just copy and
paste into your page.
[pause]
This one is one of my favorites here is a
nice looking fixed-width font.
So as coders, you may appreciate having something
nice to view your code in.
And going here, we can just edit this right
here.
So that wasn't a preview image or anything.
This is just the text running right here in
the page.
[pause]
All right.
So with that, we have a few examples.
[applause]
We're actually using this now in Google products.
So one of them that we just released is spreadsheet
forms now have templates and themes where
you can create your questionnaire or survey
and you can give it a customized look and
feel.
And this text down here is actually using
the Fonts API and we've created several different
ones of these.
This one is one of my favorites.
When I see this text there on the side, I
just have been conditioned to think, oh, this
must be an image or a plug-in or something.
But this is actually just plain text using
the Fonts API and you can see it fits really
nicely into the page.
And this has several benefits.
The fact that it's just plain text as opposed
to an image or plug-in means there's not this
large download that someone has to do.
An image, right, takes a ginormous amount
of data to, to transmit compared to just text
characters.
And in addition things like screen readers
will have no problem reading this text.
So this actually improves accessibility.
[pause]
Editing is another headache.
If you're going to have to make changes on
this and you're relying on images, you have
to edit it, take a screen shot, upload the
picture.
Here, you just change the text.
So we have quite a few of these that we created.
We had a lot of fun with these.
There's a lot of variety and great things
that you can do with, with these different
fonts.
[pause]
All right.
So if you've enjoyed this so far I have one
more piece of good news which is that we've
taken these fonts that we've either licensed
or created and we're making them all available
through an open license.
[audience cheers and applauds]
So these are all available either under the
open font license or Apache 2 license.
So you're free to take these fonts, use them
in your own applications or sites and redistribute
them.
[pause]
All right.
And so with that, you can find out all the
details on this and actually some of the more
advanced features with the Web Fonts API at
code.google.com/apis/webfonts.
I wanted to mention, too, we actually have
a JavaScript API that gives you more fine-grain
control on how these fonts are fetched or
rendered.
So you can really customize this to your heart's
content.
And then we also have a talk that touches
on web fonts along with some other topics
in HTML5 and that's tomorrow at 3:00 p.m.
in room –
>>DeWitt: Today.
>>Jeff: Oh, today.
Thank you, at 3:00 p.m. in room five.
[pause]
And so with that, we'll wrap things up.
>>DeWitt: That's great.
So we showed you a lot today.
Thank you for sticking with us.
So we showed you how to add search to your
site using the Custom Search element.
We showed you how to bring content to your
site using the Google Feed API.
We showed you how to bring revenue to your
site using Google Checkout and the new features
of Google AdSense.
We showed you how to make your site more interactive
with Buzz, and SideWiki, and Wave.
And maybe the best thing ever, we showed you
how to make the web more beautiful using the
Google Font API.
You can tell I'm particularly excited about
that one.
And, yeah, and all of these things, really,
anybody in this room can do this.
I mean, this is copy and paste.
You walk through the wizards.
You shouldn't have to be a computer scientist
to do, you know, search, or content, or to
make money with your website.
So Jeff and I are happy to take some questions
now.
We have this Wave going right here at goo.gl/Ze99.
We'll open it up, we'll take a look to see
if people had questions in the moderator.
If you have questions for us and you're in
the room, please use the microphone.
It'll make my mother happy when she watches
on YouTube.
So great.
Thank you everyone.
Okay.
[applause]
>>DeWitt: Where's the Wave?
Questions?
>>Jeff: Does anybody have any questions?
Sir?
>>Audience Member: So you can -- I think it's
really cool that you can add the Wave Element
to a web site.
I haven't tried that yet, though.
But the one thing I was worried about is,
like, what if somebody goes in and deletes
all the comments?
>>DeWitt: Well, so Wave of course, is revision
based.
>>Audience Member: Yeah.
>>DeWitt: And if you don't like something
that happens in the Wave, you can revert to
any point in time very fine-grain revision
model.
>>Audience Member: But, like, I mean, who's
going to be watching that and always reverting
if people are vandalizing that?
I dunno.
>>DeWitt: Yeah.
>>Audience Member: It seems kinda hard.
>>DeWitt: I think that's a really good question.
I've had a couple public Waves that have evolved
over time and either they evolve into a community
where a community of people actually keep
an eye on it or at some point you remove public
write access.
You say, okay.
I do this with blog comments on my own site.
After 30 days I shut out blog comments because
after that, it's mostly just spammers.
>>Audience Member: What I think would be nice
is if people who post on it were able to make
sure that other people don't modify their
comments, but I don't know.
Like, if you had that same sort of user permission.
Anyway.
>>DeWitt: Yeah.
No argument from me.
I know that the Wave team is giving a number
of talks over at Google I/O and you should
ask them about that.
>>Audience Member: Cool.
>>DeWitt: Thanks.
>>Audience Member: So I was wondering if there
were plans to support Push within GWT.
>>DeWitt: Push within GWT.
I think there are ways to do that but it's
interesting because it requires a server side
component.
>>Audience Member: Right.
>>DeWitt: So the Feed API is two things.
It's a JavaScript client that we just showed
you.
So we showed you the interface that you would
work with as the developer but then that is
making requests up to a server and the -- in
all honesty, the hard part is on the server
of managing, you know, large numbers of concurrent
connections.
>>Audience Member: Yeah. Yeah.
>>DeWitt: I -- the GWT guys are here this
week so we should ask them if they have any
server side components that they're working
with.
>>Jeff: Yeah. There's also, there's also,
there's also some details along those lines
with Bret's talks, the one we mentioned earlier,
if you wanna go to that.
[pause]
>>Audience Member: Hi.
With the Fonts API, is performance affected
with large amounts of text, or is it best
used sparingly or –
>>DeWitt: Well, if you hand the mic to the
guy to your right.
[Laughing]
>>Audience Member: Yeah.
The guy from the Fonts API team.
>>Ray Flavine: I'm Ray Flavine.
I'm one of the engineers on the Fonts API
so feel free to see me after also with more
questions.
But there's a small download for the font
itself that ranges from about 17K to over
100K per font and then once that's downloaded
-- and that's once per font.
So no matter how many sites are using the
fonts that it should be downloaded once and
cached.
Once it's in the browser, there really is
no performance impact.
You can do as much text as you like, you can
do body copy, huge amounts, and the performance
should be about the same as for native fonts.
Can I do the other two that are on the moderator?
They're great questions.
What user web browsers?
We have not yet turned on support for mobile
web browsers.
That's very high up in our list.
Again, it's mostly the download of 20 to 100K.
Once it's there, again, the performance should
be pretty good.
Also, we're only in western European Latin
one character set today but we expect that
to change pretty soon.
CJK is very challenging.
Those fonts can be up over a megabyte so we're
actively working on how to bring those down
but expect cool new things with languages
in the next -- in the coming months.
Thanks a lot.
>>DeWitt: Thank you.
[applause]
>>Audience Member: That's gonna be hard to
follow.
As a web site designer, where would you place
Buzz, versus SideWiki, versus Wave?
What's the usage case?
Why would I use one over the other?
>>DeWitt: The answer gets actually more complicated
today at 1:45 as we roll out read/write support
for Google Buzz.
But you didn't hear it from me.
Right now I would do something like I would
allow people -- I would definitely put a Google
Buzz button on my site.
I would want to syndicate that out.
Over the long term, I hope that we see more
sites federating comments, Buzz style comments,
using a protocol called "Salmon".
And then I would integrate Buzz-style comments
into either my existing comment feed or maybe
even more interesting, I would build a Buzz
robot that could speak Salmon and go pull
in Buzz comments into a Wave.
Sorry.
Did I say that right?
>>Jeff: Yeah.
>>DeWitt: I would build a Wave robot that
would pull in Buzz comments which I think
would be very exciting.
Or you can do something like you saw the guys
at Read Write Web playing with which is use
a Wave as a commenting widget.
>>Audience Member: One though there is that
with Wave you have that extra level of interactivity
when you embed thaaat.
I haven't done this yet so when you embed
that Wave, are you able to add in all that
level of interactivity throughout the map
or is it simply comments?
>>Jeff: Yeah.
The example we showed earlier actually on
the Read Write web post somebody actually
added the pole gadget and everything.
So yeah.
All of the -- it's basically all the features
just embedded running right in Wave.
>>DeWitt: It is a Wave in the page, a full
Wave.
>>Audience Member: Another web fonts question.
>>DeWitt: Yeah.
>>Audience Member: If I heard you guys right,
you're talking about bringing web fonts to
IE 6 with the Font API and so I'm wondering
what is the range of browsers that this will
work with?
>>Ray: Sure.
It's IE 6 and up, it's Chrome since 4.0 which
shipped in January, it's Firefoz since 3.5,
it's Safari for over a year, Opera 10.5 is
-- does work and I'm sure I've missed one
-- I'm sure I missed one but we're at about
98 percent of the browsers that are actually
out there in the world.
[pause]
>>DeWitt: Good question.
>>Audience Member: I have a question regarding
the autosuggest.
Thank you for creating that autosuggest for
Google Custom Search.
As a developer, I have been trying to add
a Custom Search autosuggest to my search box
and I have been using jpeg3 but it doesn't
work that well.
My question is, the autosuggest, can you specify
for a specific site so the autosuggest still
work on the site?
>>Jeff: Right.
Yeah.
So the completions, the autocomplete data
is actually targeted for that Custom Search
Engine.
So each one sort of grows its own set of autocompletions
and right now you can't specify your own,
like, things that you would like to surface
but yeah.
Over time, you know, it sort of grows.
>>DeWitt: Right.
>>Jeff: And it is targeted to a specific Custom
Search Engine.
>>Audience Member: Thank you very much.
>>DeWitt: And also let us know if you want
more flexibility in the way that the autocompletions
are done.
Like you want to also populate it with your
own autocompletions.
[pause]
>>DeWitt: Cool.
Well, thank you all for coming.
We really appreciate the opportunity to talk
about all these things.
This'll be on YouTube and great seeing everyone.
Thanks.
[applause]